[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hello hello Mirko heute wird's
richtig spannend und vor allem glamourös
wir haben heute eine Hollywood Folge
tada ja es geht um einen echten wie der
Amerikaner sagen würde nailbiter also um
einen Fall bei dem du dir die
Fingernägel abkaust weil er so spannend
ist wir präsentieren euch einen
mysteriösen Fall mitten aus der
Traumfabrik es geht um Promis Luxus Sex
Alkohol und eine Leiche aber wir müssen
dazu sagen und da sind wir ganz ehrlich
wir sind uns selbst nicht ganz sicher zu
welchem Genre die Geschichte eigentlich
gehört die wir euch heute erzählen ist
es ein Drama mit einem unglücklichen
Opfer oder vielleicht doch eher ein
Thriller mit einem brutalen Täter tja
nicht ganz einfach heute geht es um den
mysteriösen Fall der Natalie Wood wie
starb Hollywoods Wunderkind und einer
der schillernsten Stars der Traumfabrik
das wird eine geheimnisvolle Folge mit
vielen Rätseln schön dass ihr dabei seid
wir sind Tony haer und Mirko kimir
hallo es ist der 29 November
1981 morgen ist angebrochen auf Santa
Catalina Island dieser hübschen kleinen
Insel im Pazifik direkt vor der Küste
von Los Angeles tja und wie schön es
hier ist felsige Landschaft angenehmes
Klima viel Sonne wunderschöne Buchten
cant Catalina ist ein Paradies nur
wenige Kilometer Luftlinie entfernt vom
pulsierenden Leben in LA und der
Filmfabrik in Hollywood die See ist
etwas rauer als sonst an diesem
novembermgen auch das Wetter in der
Nacht zuvor war nicht wirklich gut es
war stürmisch und regnerisch am Morgen
hat sich das Wetter etwas beruhigt doch
was treibt da im Wasser ist das etwa ein
Mensch wirklich gruselig im Wasser
treibt ein toter Mensch an diesem Morgen
des 29 November zieht die Polizei eine
Leiche aus dem Pazifik ganz in der Nähe
der kavank der blaue höhlenbucht von
Santa Catalina die Tote ist weiblich
Anfang 40 und treibt mit dem Gesicht
nach unten im Wasser sie hat braune
Haare trägt Socken ein Nachthemd und
eine rote Daunenjacke am Kopf hat sie
eine schirfwunde nicht weit von ihr
entfernt treibt ein kleines Boot im
Wasser sehr bald stellt sich heraus die
Tote ist einer der damals bekanntesten
Hollywood Stars was für eine Meldung
Natalie Wood ist tot die Menschen sind
geschockt eine Schauspielerin aus
Hollywoods arriege stirbt unerwartet
Natalie Wood die Frau die viele schon
aus ihrer Zeit als Kinderstar kennen die
Frau die mit James Dean getreht hat und
die in Westside Story zu sehen war das
Leben dieser Oscar nominierten
Schauspielerin endet abrupt mit nur 43
Jahren was ist passiert in der
vergangenen Nacht was ist passiert auf
dieser Yacht diese Nacht verdient eine
eigene Überschrift denn das ist die
Nacht in der sich Natalie Woods
Schicksal entscheidet
Natalie verbringt die letzten Stunden
ihres Lebens auf einer Motorjacht vor
der Küste von Santa Catalina auf dem
Schiff namens splender mit an Bord ihr
Ehemann Robert Wagner der ist ebenfalls
ein Star hier in Deutschland bekannt aus
der 80er Jahre Fernsehserie hart aber
herzlich und einige von euch werden ihn
vielleicht aus den Austin Powers Filmen
kennen in denen er einen der Bösewichte
spielte ebenfalls zu Gast auf deracht
ist üb Wochenende ihr
Schauspielkollege Walken den kennt ihr
bestimmt aus vielen Filmen z.B auch als
bondbösewicht mit Christopher Walken
steckt Natalie Wood damals in den
Dreharbeiten zum Streifen Projekt
Brainstorm gemeinsam gönnen Sie sich
eine Auszeit und verbringen das
Wochenende beim gemeinsamen ychttausflug
ein wahres promiboot ankerte also vor
der Küste von Santa
Catalina samstag der 28 November Tag 2
des Kurztrips das Trio geht an Land um
dort in der Bar Harbor Reef Einzug her
und da lassen es die drei Promis so
richtig krachen es wird gelacht und
gebächert gebächert und gelacht Sturz
betetrunken verlassen Sie die Bar die
drei sind so alkoholisiert dass sie
sogar Hilfe vom Barpersonal bekommen die
schauen dass Robert Wagner Natalie Wood
und Christopher Walken mit dem Beiboot
sicher zurück zur Yacht kommen übrigens
genau das Beiboot das am nächsten Morgen
in der Nähe der Toten Natalie Wood im
Wasser treiben wird ja die kurze
Überfahrt ist allein schon wegen
blutalkoholgehalts der Beteiligten
schunkelige Angelegenheit und auch das
Meer ist unruhig aber nichts passiert
die drei kommen auf der Yacht an alle
sehr sehr betrunken und auf der Yacht
geht die Party weiter Natalie Wood
Robert Wagner und Christopher Walken
genehmigen sich noch ein paar Drinks im
Salon des Schiffes bis sich Natalie als
erste ins Bett verabschiedet und dann
der groe Schock alsert WAG später nach
seiner Frau sehen will sieeg nicht
h wo ist sie Wagner sucht die Yacht ab
und bemerkt dass das Beiboot Weg ist er
denkt sich dass Natalie mit dem kleinen
Boot an Land gefahren ist und er macht
sich Sorgen denn er weiß seine Frau hat
Angst vor offenem Wasser und sie kann
nicht
schwimmen am Sonntag morgen um 1:30 Uhr
greift Robert Wagner zum Funkgerät und
sendet per Funk hier ist die splendor
wir brauchen Hilfe jemand wird vermisst
doch dieser Hilferuf kommt zu spät ja in
den frühen Morgenstunden wird Natalie
Woods lebloser Körper aus dem Wasser
gezogen ca eine Meile von der Yacht
entfernt es sieht so aus als sei dies
das tragische Ende eines gemeinsamen
Ausflugs die Szene wie wir sie eben
geschildert haben lässt sich so aus dem
ersten Polizeibericht rekonstruieren
dieser Bericht stützt sich auf die
Aussagen von Robert Wagner der glaubt
nun nicht mehr dass sie noch mal
losfahren wollte sondern äußert jetzt
die Vermutung dass Natalie Wood wohl
versucht haben muss das lockere Beiboot
festzuturen und sich dabei womöglich
unglücklich am Kopf verletzt hat danach
ist sie ins Wasser gerollt und ertrunken
denn laut des obduktionsberichtes war es
ein Tod durch Ertrinken und Unterkühlung
ohne
Fremdeinwirkung also ist sie beim
festzuren des beibootes
ausgerutscht so erklärt es zumindest
Wagner das würde dann ja auch erklären
warum das Boot am nächsten Morgen nicht
weit von ihr im Wasser treibt na ja
soweit die erste offizielle Version der
Geschehnisse in dieser Nacht aber dies
wäre ja kein Fall für Tat Deutschland
wenn die Geschichte hier zu Ende wäre
richtig aber es wird ziemlich lange
dauern bis zum nächsten Akt dieses real
world Hollywood Dramas genau denn erst
2012 werden die damaligen Ermittlungen
verworfen 30 Jahre nach dem Tod von
Natalie Wood jetzt sag die Polizei wir
können nicht mehr eindeutig davon
ausgehen dass ihr Tod ein Unfall war der
Grund dafür die Gerichtsmediziner können
nicht sagen wann sich Nataly wood ihre
Verletzungen zugezogen hat also nachdem
sie ins Wasser gefallen war oder davor
davor würde bedeuten dass sie jemand vor
dem Ertrinken geschupst oder geschlagen
hat und auch das ist neu natalys man
Robert gilt von nun an auch als Person
of interest also als Person von
besonderem polizeilichen Interesse er
wird also nicht offiziell verdächtigt
aber die Ermittler haben ihn im Visier
sie vermuten dass Robert Wagner nicht
die ganze Geschichte erzählt hat im Jahr
2018 werden sogar neue Ermittlungen
aufgenommen und genau das ist Wasser auf
die Mühlen von Lana wood der Schwester
der Toten sie zweifelt schon seit
Jahrzehnten die offiziellen
Ermittlungsergebnisse der Polizei an sie
sagt der Tod ihrer Schwester war kein
Unfall viel mehr wurde sie getötet von
Robert Wagner ihrem Ehemann er war der
letzte der sie lebend gesehen hat und er
hatte ein Motiv er war wütend wegen der
angeblichen Affäre die seine Frau mit
dem Mann hatte der mit an Bord war
Christopher
Walken na das ist schon bemerkenswert
also drei Jahrzehnte später sagen die
Behörden dass ihre ursprüngliche Theorie
zum Tod von Natalie Wood nicht mehr
haltbar ist und ehrlich gesagt Mirko das
war auch überfällig oder ja denn die
besagte Nacht auf der Jagt ist eine
Nacht voller Widersprüche und
Ungereimtheiten und die lassen einen
schon Grübeln zurück kann das wirklich
ein tragischer Unfall gewesen sein na ja
also kann man sich denn beim Festmachen
eines beibootes wirklich so stark
verletzen na ja vielleicht war es ja
auch ganz anders vielleicht ist nal wood
nachts noch mal los vielleicht aus Wut
immerhin haben sie und Robert Wagner
sich gestritten das hat er ja sogar
selber zugegeben und sie ist dann auf
offener See
ertrunken ich weiß nicht also ich meine
sie war nicht schwürmerin und hat ihr
Leben lang panische Angst vor offenem
Wasser gehabt da hat sie auch schon ganz
offen in Interviews drüber gesprochen
ihre Schwester sagt sie hätte sich
niemals wirklich niemals getraut die
alleine zu verlassen das macht mich
schon stutzig zumal ich mich auch frage
wieso trägt sie dann nur Socken ein
Nachthemd und eine Jacke hätte sie sich
nicht Hose und Schuhe angezogen also für
mich passt das irgendwie nicht so ganz
zusammen guter Punkt und dann gibt's ja
auch noch die Aussagen von zwei Personen
vom Nachbarboot die haben nicht nur den
Streit gehört von dem wir ja schon
wissen sondern auch eine Frau die nach
Hilfe geschrieen hat war das eventuell
die verzweifelte Stimme von Natal W
kampf ein anderer Zeuge gibt an einen
Mann und eine Frau gesehen zu haben die
sich am Heck des Bootes gestritten
hätten dieser Zeuge vermutet dass es
sich um wood und Wagner
handelte belastet wird Robert Wagner
auch von Dennis davn dem Kapitän der mit
an Bord war auch er sagt Natalie Wood
und Robert Wagner haben sich in der
Nacht heftigst gestritten von etweigen
hilfeerufen von Natalie spricht er
allerdings nicht also ich finde in der
ganzen erzählung gibt Robert Wagner
keine gute Figur ab es wirkt irgendwie
als habe er es überhaupt nicht eilig
seine verschwundene Frau wiederzufinden
so bemerkte Wagner bereits gegen
Mitternacht dass seine Frau verschwunden
ist den Hilferuf per Funk sendet er aber
erst um 1:30 Uhr also ganze 90 Minuten
später da fragt man sich doch wieso
wartest du so lange wenn du dir doch
Sorgen machst und hinzu kommt Robert
Wagner hat den Kapitän zunächst davon
abgehalten die Polizei zu rufen und er
hat auch verhindert dass die
Suchscheinwerfer eingeschaltet werden
angeblich aus Angst vor dem Paparazzi
und da frage ich mich wenn du wirklich
Angst um jemanden hast sind dir die
Paparazzi da nicht egal dann machst du
doch trotzdem sofort die
Suchscheinwerfer an und du rufst sofort
die Polizei auf jeden Fall das alles ist
wirklich schon sehr sehr verdächtig und
dann sind da ja noch die
Ermittlungsbehörden die anscheinend
nicht gerade den besten Job gemacht
haben ja zehnte lang gab es den Vorwurf
dass die Polizei den Fall vertuschen
wollte dass die Verletzungen an Natalie
Woods Körper nicht vernünftig untersucht
und im Bericht angegeben wurden und in
der Tat der Autopsiebericht wurde 2013
geändert in dem neuen Bericht werden
Kratzer und Blutergüsse aufgeführt von
denen im ursprungsbericht nicht die Rede
war Verletzungen an Armen Beinen unter
Stirn hm sieh mal ein an die
Journalistin Susan finstad beschreibt in
der von ihr geschriebenen Natalie Wood
Biografie die Leiche sah so aus als wäre
sie vor ihrem Tod verprügelt worden okay
aber dann haben wir den Fall ja geklärt
ne es war also kein Unfall es war Mord
und Robert Wagner war der Killer na ja
ganz so einfach ist natürlich nicht die
Polizei sagt zwar dass alles sei sehr
verdächtig aber sie geht nicht so weit
Robert Wagner anzuklagen denn dafür
reichen die Beweise einfach nicht nicht
aus Robert Wagner wird aber weiterhin
als Person of interest bezeichnet was in
diesem Fall so viel bedeutet wie wir
können dir zwar nichts nachweisen aber
so ganz aus dem Schneider bist du nicht
denn dein Verhalten ist schon sehr
verdächtig wir bleiben da mal dran wir
ermitteln weiter aber nicht alle sehen
Robert Wagner als vermeindlichen Täter
dessen Adoptivtochter also die leibliche
Tochter von Natalie Wood die nimmt ihnen
Schutz und das sehr nachdrücklich
Natasha Gregson Wagner sagt es sei ein
Unglück gewesen sie ist felsenfest davon
überzeugt dass ihr Vater sein Leben für
ihre Mutter gegeben hätte und ihr sowas
schlimmes niemals angetan hätte sag mal
MKO über eine Variante haben wir aber
noch gar nicht gesprochen okay was
meinst du na Suizid hat sich Natalie WD
vielleicht selbst umgebracht das wäre ja
nicht ihr erster Selbstmordversuch
gewesen ja das könnte natürlich sein in
den 60er Jahren hat sich naly wood schon
mal versucht das Leben zu nehmen aber
das halte ich für eher unwahrscheinlich
erstens gibt es keinen Abschiedsbrief
und dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage
würde sich Natalie Wood tatsächlich
ausgerechnet für einen Freitod im Wasser
entscheiden wo sie doch ihr ganzes Leben
lang wirklich panische Angst vor
ertrinken hatte also ich vermute dass
hätte sie sich wirklich umbringen wollen
Sie eine andere Art und Weise gefunden
hätte sich das Leben zu nehmen
aber dann war es am Ende vielleicht der
Alkohol du meinst Alkohol als Täter na
ja also zumindest im übertragenen Sinne
vielleicht lag es ja wirklich am Alkohol
dass sie gestorben ist die haben an dem
Abend J nun wirklich richtig doll
gebechert so wie es aussieht wie wär es
denn mit dieser Version so ähnlich wie
Robert Wagners Aussage aber doch ein
bisschen anders Natalie Wood ist wütend
sie entscheidet sich nach dem Streit mit
ihrem Mann an Land zu schlafen obwohl
sie eigentlich Angst vor dem Wasser hat
entschließt sie sich volltrunken das
Beiboot zu nehmen und überzusetzen
während sie das Boot losmacht stolpert
sie verletzt sich am Kopf und fällt ins
Wasser wo sie dann eben ertrinkt das
würde erklären warum sie sich überhaupt
noch mal am Beiboot zu schaffen gemacht
hat das wä ein tragisches Unglück das
nicht passiert wäre wenn Natalie Wood
z.B nicht dann gewesen wäre ja ist
durchaus eine Möglichkeit und die
schließt die Polizei ja auch weiterhin
nicht aus aber wie wä es mit dieser
Version Natalie Wood entscheidet sich
also nach dem Streit mit ihrem Mann an
Land zu schlafen obwohl sie Angst vor
dem Wasser hat entschließt sie sich
dennoch das Beiboot zu nehmen um aufs
Festland überzusetzen sie ist nämlich so
wütend dass sie es nicht erträgt weiter
auf der Yacht zu bleiben ihr Mann Robert
Wagner folgt ihr zum Beiboot und schlägt
wütend auf sie ein sie fällt zu Boden
und er schubst seine ohnmächtige Frau
ins Wasser wo sie dann ertrinkt Robert
Wagner geht zurück in die Yacht und
spielt später den besorgten Ehemann der
so tut als wisse er nicht wo seine
geliebte Frau ist aber das ist natürlich
nur reine
Spekulation auch eine Möglichkeit und
das ist ja das Spannende auch dieses
Szenario schließt die Polizei neuerdings
nicht mehr aus das Problem ist aber
keiner hat beobachtet wie Nataly wood
von Bord gegangen ist also höchstens
Robert Wagner aber der wird sich wenn er
es denn gewesen wäre ja wohl kaum
selbstbelasten also können wir von
seiner Seite aus auch keine neuen
Erkenntnisse erwarten hat Robert Wagner
bei seiner betrunkenen Frau nachgeholfen
um sie aus dem Weg zu schaffen oder hat
er wirklich nichts mit ihrem Tod zu tun
so viele Hobbydetektive und Journalisten
haben schon über diesen Fall Bücher
geschrieben es gibt investigative
Artikel und jede Menge Interviews doch
endgültige Klarheit über die
Geschehnisse in der Todesnacht haben die
alle nicht gebracht
der Tod von Natalie Wood er bleibt
mysteriös und so wie es aussieht wird er
es bis in alle Ewigkeit bleiben und
deshalb haben wir euch zu Beginn dieser
Folge gesagt dass wir nicht wissen was
dieser Fall ist also eine Tragödie mit
einem unglücklichen Opfer oder einem
psychoriller mit einem brutalen Mörder
ja diese Frage bleibt leider offen aber
spannend ist allemal der mysteriöse Tod
der Natalie Wood in jedem Fall ein W
Podcast Blockbuster würde ich mal sagen
wir haben für diesen Fall unter anderem
auf Beiträge des Spiegel der Berliner
Zeitung des Tagesspiegels und der Welt
zurückgegriffen wir danken euch dass ihr
wieder mit dabei wart und freuen uns
immer über Anregung und Kritik von euch
ihr könnt uns dafür gerne eine Mail
schicken oder uns bei Instagram
schreiben wir freuen uns von euch zu
hören und damit bis zum nächsten mal
euer Mirko und eure
Tony
dir hat diese Folge von tout Deutschland
gefallen du bekommst von True Crime
einfach nicht genug dann hör jetzt in
unsere weiteren Folgen rein hier warten
mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf dich
wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca Rusch
der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder die
Entführung von ursela Hermann wir hören
uns bei Tat Deutschland